quel cadeau 2007 florence merci d'être
là alors nous triomphé dans toutes les
salles de france partout vous passer
c'est complet je sais très bien ce que
vous allez dire suis tombé sur une de
vos fiches en loge êtes jeunes vous êtes
drôle est belle non ça c'est la fiche
des ateliers
[Applaudissements]
l'an passé j'avais écrit vous êtes drôle
mais par contre c'est méchant le
charmant il cherchait j'aime pas par
contre non je me dis en effet ce n'est
peut-être pas la peine qu'on se refasse
une interview on va peut-être changer de
place
à temps regarde pas ce que je vis
m
[Applaudissements]
je vous dise quand même votre
anniversaire dans l'eau spatm on
l'espère les autres rien tu
en rêvais regarde je vais faire tout
comme toi alors j'en ai jeté fiche à toi
j'ai les miennes
je le pense
[Applaudissements]
jean-louis là qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va maintenant je vais voir ma petite
gorgée de gevrey chambertin draps
[Applaudissements]
égard
voilà tu me mets le filtre belle gueule
1 c'est mieux avec un [ __ ] parce que
sans jouer enfin voilà au quai d'orsay
on va pouvoir y aller alors fais moi le
décompte hier jeudi on fait comme si on
y était
le médecin
[Musique]
salut les terriens
je vis à vis un bon soir
[Applaudissements]
dupriez en fait c'est pour faire croire
qu'il ya une ambiance de fou sur le
plateau
alors ce soir d'intérieur de choix et un
robot gens me sarah janvier cheetah
gueule bonsoir laws in les gréements
porte hull
[Musique]
non c'était pas pour vous il y avait un
moucheron
alors tout de suite j'accueille le
terrien du samedi 20h j'accueille
thierry ardisson
[Applaudissements]
donc on ya que toi que ça marche quoique
ans et moins avec lorca ça marche
qu'avec les samples j'aime mieux le
sampler alors
alors thierry
ardisson vous avez 60 ans thierry ils
ont décollé mais parce que bien quoi
[ __ ] une forêt à chaque émission c'est
pas parce que j'y vois pas parce qu'il
serait peut-être pas juste en 2009 une
aide si regardez moi
[Applaudissements]
et moi
moins que dix sur dix sont deux vieux ça
tient sur une page web avis sur vire
alors thierry donc je vous disais vous
êtes l'animateur qu'on ne présente plus
vous êtes venu nous raconter votre
terrible histoire oui mais que je vais
plutôt racontez moi même pendant que
vous faites lui la tête dans un seau
d'eau chaude ben alla jusqu'à ce que je
pleure ça vous va quand même un rien
rebelle non mais répondait pas parce que
là on fait des plans de coupes faites
juste des réactions comme moi regardez
regardez tout ce que je peux donner en
quelques secondes regardez là c'est
quand je suis passionné ça c'est quand
je m'intéresse à ces camps j'imite
hitler pour
la suite quand je m'emmerde n'était
souvent pas
ça laisse à la fin
ça c'est quand je pense à alessandra
sublet
c 5 attention
[Musique]
alors thierry ac en plus vous le faites
comme ça alors que c'est très gros un
confort de très grosses lunettes alors
thierry avant la télé vous démarrez
votre carrière dans la publicité avoue
marqué durablement l'histoire de la
langue française d'ailleurs en
l'enrichissant de brillants de formules
telles que la paire et en a pas deux
chaussée aux moines amen
et encore vas-y vas-y
[Applaudissements]
et c'est donc tout naturellement qu on
vous confie il ya quelques années les
rênes d'une émission culturelle sur une
chaîne du service public la france a
toujours su reconnaître ses élites alors
en 98 de vous lancer tout le monde en
parle et tout le monde en parle c'était
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à bolbec des merveilles
face on n'a pas l'image vous irez sur
youtube et tenait à temps mais c'est
vrai que l'émission devient très vite
culte incontournables vous présenter le
talk show de plus en vue de paris vous
vous atteignez des sommets d'audience et
c'est donc tout naturellement qu on vous
vire parce que logique et normal la
france a toujours su reconnaître c'est
elie et là
c'est le drame
ce trophée d'un temps pour moi je ne
connais pas le merde me suis trompé de
bouton donnant là c'est le drame
[Musique]
ah ça marche
on naît le 8 juillet 2006
non j'ai pas de trou est fait exprès
pour mettre de la tension
patrick de carolis alors président de
france télévisions vous contraint
finalement acquitté la chaîne car vous
refusez de mettre fin à votre autre
émission 93
honoré
c'est une émission vous affectionnez
particulièrement que ça me permet
d'inviter vos pâtes à bouffer sans faire
les courses bien sûr
alors ça fait quoi de se faire virer par
le gars qui présente des racines et des
ailes
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas de questions
lors de désespoir vous lui écrivait une
lettre lui disant c'est un miracle que
tu fusille mais entre les lignes on peut
aisément lire ecoute moi bien fils de
[ __ ] tu t'en rendras les coudes toujours
ce sens de la formule bien sûr résultat
vous quitter france 2 je vous retrouve l
arle bon la rue de rivoli vous me direz
ça va quand même
maintenant mais nous ici c'est le
cabinet deux heures après que la terre
ait un jour on déguste en un kebab en
bas de chez vous
ou bien tu une idée
mais elle pourrit donc vous reprenez un
kebab puis un autre jour votre téléphone
sonne c'est canal + web qui vous propose
de prendre le bouquet canalsat
gratuitement pendant six mois
[Applaudissements]
ça vous acceptez et on zappe en bas vous
réalisez que finalement il n'y a pas
d'émission présenté par vous-même quoi
ex-amante vous décidé de revenir à
l'antenne pour présenter salut les
terriens sur canal qui
[Applaudissements]
nous découvrent et des conditions de
travail abominable et parle déjà vous
travaillé deux jours 19h15
à l'ombre 1 vous êtes obligé de vous
adresser à des gens sommes
gens normaux qui boivent de l'eau quoi
le défi est énorme et tout ça sur une
chaîne at elle fait blood audience là
vous comprenez enfin la malédiction des
gens qui travaillent sur canal+ quand
vous les croisez dans la rue les gens
ali dont vous avez pu arrêter ceux ci
chez sur canal c'est ce que je dis on ne
voit plus à la télé sera bienvenu
au niveau moi alors c'est sûr qu'au
niveau niveau des invités au basson
gamme évidemment c'est la dégringolade
avant vous aviez madonna maintenant vous
avez madénian vous aviez bruce willis
vous avez bruce toussaint vous aviez
sydney pollack vous avez sydney a chipé
à choper même laurent baffie a été
remplacé pour des raisons économiques
parce que c'est moins cher c'est sûr
mais c'est moins drôle regard des gens
me dit quelque chose quand c'est tout
c'est tropicaux est moins drôle
je n'aime pas ce robot c'est moins drôle
aussi
et pourtant et pourtant et pourtant
thierry vous allez remettre de vos
cendres vous arrêter la drogue vous
arrêter non non non
les informations en tous cas vous
arrêterez-vous météo sport bref bouton
berceau on nous la fait pas et là ça
marche l'audience remonte l'émission
devient une incontournable de canal plus
la preuve ce soir nous sommes là pour
fêter les 10 ans de salut les terriens
[Applaudissements]
puisque l'émission a démarré en novembre
2006 on est en 2015 je vous laisse faire
le calcul
je sais pas
pour faire sa marque et ça m'arrange si
on allait maintenant tous les dix ans
moi j'ai 36 ans et ça me va très bien
alors fêter les 10 ans d'une émission
qui dans la cnops ça veut dire que vous
êtes toujours en avance sur votre temps
alors il est comment l'iphone cette
allée tout de suite en cadeau
l'interview dans dix ans au nom
[Musique]
anti ride en disant vous serez ou là ici
ou là là ouais ouais ou peut-être là
soixante seize bornes
en disant que dira-t-on de vous dégage
mais non bâti il y aura plein de jeunes
j'espère qu'ils arriveront et kelly
grandes villes pourquoi tu me regardes
pas ce que tu m'as déjà viré une fois
en disant qu est ce qui vous fera peur
de ne plus pouvoir courir deux fois
trente minutes par semaine
on est là on en est là en travaux
ça veut dire qu'ils vendent déjà plus
dans dix ans quelle drogue consommerait
vous encore toujours des pétards et ça
fera 60 ans que je fumerai des pétards
dans dix ans
[Applaudissements]
à l'ordre du temps un qui sera le nouvel
ardisson
peut-être yann barthès n'ont
finalement dans dix ans est ce que jean
mi marchera encore j'ai envie dirigera
canal dans du bois ah ouais bah écoutez
c'est tout ce qu'on vous souhaite
[Applaudissements]
je viens d'économiser dix
ans plus tard
[Applaudissements]
florence foresti mais la mission
merci merci de me rendre ma place
contrairement à l'or ont été
mes samedis soirs sont proches de vous
au moins vous demander ma place alors
une question que j'ai jamais posé la
personne florence ça fait quoi des tirs
et ardisson c'est hyper dur en faire
mais est ce qu on croit que c'est facile
ouais ouais ouais y'a pas que ça quoi et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux